welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
the heat is being turned up on one of
the most outspoken members of congress
florida republican matt
gates rather is the target of an
investigation into whether he violated
federal sex
trafficking laws major garrett reports
the investigation into matt gates a
staunch ally of former president trump
is growing
now involving several offices of the
justice department
a top aide to the congressman resigning
as the scandal widens
at issue is gates relationship with a
17-year-old girl
gates could face federal charges if he
traveled across state lines
or provided anything of value airplane
tickets meals hotel rooms
in exchange for sex with her something
he has denied
it is a horrible allegation and it is a
lie gates could also face state
charges of prostitution the new york
times reported obtaining receipts
suggesting gates and an associate joel
greenberg
paid for sex after using websites to
locate potential partners
greenberg was indicted last year on sex
trafficking charges
gates's congressional office said matt
gates has never paid for sex
matt gates has never been on any such
websites whatsoever
categorical denials are all about a
political career right now
scott frederickson is a former federal
prosecutor prosecutors don't pay a lot
of attention to that
what they're paying attention is do they
have the witness to prove their
allegations
the new york times said it also spoken
with people familiar with the sexual
encounters and two said the drug
ecstasy was involved gates recently
became engaged as news worsened for him
this week radio silence from
congressional republicans
gates has not been charged with any
crimes at this stage he is a subject
not a target of this wide-ranging
federal investigation
for cbs this morning saturday major
garrett washington